some people like to watch bonus content
you are the bonus content you were the
living bonus content there you go says
it on my business
card welcome to Monarch
General this is going to give me
nightmares one of the things that really
appealed to us was that before now
you're always inside Monarch everybody
gets a park exactly everybody has the
Branded Monarch GE and what we wanted to
do was turn the perspective around and
have group of characters who are on the
outside looking
in what's Monarch I don't know Monarch
is just as unknown and monstrous and
scary are these guys good guys or bad
guys we don't know the whole city was
coming down these guys were taking
pictures we want to pull back the
curtain on that and show you how it
became the organization that you now
see we have to bring Monarch Out of the
Shadows going into the monsterverse we
had to figure out what's the best
version of the show the first question I
asked was does it have to be about the
monsters I think it should be about this
messed up family and it's that Journey
that takes you into the world of the
[Music]
monsters in this new world monsters are
like hurricanes it's a reality of the
world you live in let's tell a story
about people with that as the Spectrum a
lot of the monsterverse fans are going
to come for the Titans they're going to
come for cities being knocked down but
the show will be about people getting
back up again the only way out is
through our internal shorthand has been
like it's not a 911 show it's a 912 show
it's about the first time you have to
take your shoes off at the airport this
changes everything it's a story about
the Titans but also about a group of
people who are dealing with their own
monsters everybody's dealing with their
own monsters it is your family business
it's the family
curse over the season we hop from era to
era and fill in more of the blanks but
not all of them so we still have
questions to answer and we're asking
even more that push everything forward
if you come with me you'll know
everything I promise
you oh my God go go
[Music]
go